c'était le point culminant de la fin de
semaine de la fierté gay à toronto l'un
des plus importants défilés du genre en
amérique du nord
plus de 200 chars allégoriques ont
déambulé dans les rues pour célébrer la
diversité et philippe des centaines de
milliers de personnes participaient à
l'événement
oui tout à fait la prévoir l'énergie est
vraiment énergie est vraiment électrique
contagieuse a pu voir partout autour de
moi les chara l'a bien confus des deux
passes et il y avait environ 200 ont
fait plus de 200 organisations qui sont
représentées qui passe un pour arroser
et lancer des petits des petits cadeaux
aux festivaliers au chat qui lui sont
venues elles sont vraiment des centaines
de milliers de personnes à être revenus
dans les rues du centre-ville
je vais écouter quelques parties qu'est
ce que c'est le festival j je suis un
des membres de la communauté
je suis vraiment bien et je pense que
c'est pas très amusant c'est la première
fois que je vois ça à cause de mon ami
là et puis je suis venu le voir et puis
il m'a amené ici et puis j'aime beaucoup
ton tour c'est une ville très libéral à
quelques mois des élections les
politiciens n'est pas manquer pareille
occasion
why à de nombreux politiciens qui était
excitant de tous les ordres de
gouvernements municipal provincial et
fédéral le premier ministre justin
trudeau était de la partie comme tout
comme le chef néodémocrate jack meeting
quand vous voulez que je vous avais
laissé entendre dans un instant mais
parmi les grands absents il ya le
premier ministre ontarien d'oxford et le
chef conservateur el béchir est là tu
vois si elle
voici les cinq meetings et cette ruse ou
alors au tour une opportunité encore une
fois pour moi de marché avec fierté dans
une parade de la fierté
j'ai bien hâte à tous les autres
évènements de cet essai était aussi les
ont vécu une discrimination historique
de la puce du policier est encore
quelque chose qui c'est qui êtes arrivés
plus récemment
donc je comprends les sentiments de ki
moon était âgé dé vécu donc voilà les
festivités se poursuivent tout au long
de la soirée c'est quand même un défilé
qu'ils ont plusieurs heures donc on
s'attend encore à sec plusieurs chars
allégoriques eepad au cours des
prochaines heures
merci beaucoup philippe